it's a a great way for the citizens to
get involved it's a crime fighting tool
that's been around for decades that
number right there on your screen
702-385-55 and according to the team
behind the non-profit organization it's
been crucial to keeping our streets safe
since this Inception uh Crime Stoppers
has received I believe it's March of
this year of 2022 approximately 400 000
tips from citizens uh 200 000 of those
tips have actually been processed and
out of those 200 000 tips almost 11 000
felony arrests have been made and pretty
much totaling everything together I have
paid out about 1.6 million dollars to uh
our uh our citizens throughout the
community so overall it's working it is
absolutely working Crime Stoppers dating
back to 1976 in Albuquerque New Mexico
when a frustrated detective noticed
cases were not being solved and he would
go through the community and he realized
that
the community and citizens felt
comfortable giving him tips but not
everybody tips and so he wanted to bring
together
the community the media and law
enforcement and provide an anonymous way
for people to provide tips that would
help solve these cases within the
community that Crime Stoppers platform
was created and quickly spreading across
the country and overseas in 1979
Southern Nevada embraced it and even
replacing it with its similar program
called secret witness with only five
hundred dollars in its account Crime
Stoppers helps us to identify and locate
some of those individuals that are
committing those heinous crimes within
our community without the help of the
citizens of our community we wouldn't be
able to identify them or we wouldn't be
able to locate them and they would
continue to be repeat offenders
organization officials tell us people
would not come forward over the fear of
intimidation but with the anonymous Pro
protocol it gives tipsters a layer of
confidentiality and reassurance today
Crime Stoppers looking for more than
just tips to keep handing out those
rewards it comes from a lot of sources
uh some one of the sources is Corporate
Partnerships like the Las Vegas
Metropolitan Foundation
they're a big supporter of our
organization and their donations help
pay for our tips